let me bring you some breaking news now
according to malaysia's founder rosmah
mansour the wife of former prime
minister najib radzak guilty in a
corruption trial rasma mansour was found
guilty of three counts of bribery she
was charged for soliciting and receiving
bribes to help a company win a contract
her husband najib began a 12-year prison
term last week after being convicted of
corruption involving the malaysian state
fund 1 ndb florence louise live for us
in kuala lumpur just give us a little
bit of the background on what's been
happening thorns
that's right so she was charged with
three charges um
soliciting and receiving bribes of
around one and a half million dollars
between the years 2016 and 2017. it was
allegedly it was to help a company win a
government project to supply solar
panels to schools now the judge said he
found that the prosecution had proved
their case beyond reasonable doubt
defense lawyers had argued that ross mar
mansour had been framed by a former aide
and other officials but clearly this
the that argument did not sit with the
judge now her lawyers had also put in a
last-minute bid to have the judge
dismissed
her critics have said that this was a
ploy to buy more time and ultimately
that application to have the judge
dismissed was dismissed it was heard
earlier this morning it was argued this
morning by her lawyers but it was
ultimately dismissed and the judge went
on to deliver the verdict and he's now
found her guilty on all three charges
and we don't yet know what the sentence
is we expect that to be delivered any
moment now but she could receive a
maximum of up to 20 years in prison and
beats and be asked to pay a fine for at
least five times the amount of bribes
that she had received but we do expect
her lawyers to i mean it's very likely
that her lawyers will file an appeal and
we do expect her to remain out on bail
she has been out on bail all as well and
she could also file an application for a
stay of sentence while she tries to
exhaust all avenues of appeal
florence as i mentioned before
her husband najib razak the former prime
minister has just begun a 12-year prison
term after being convicted of corruption
how is all of this playing out with the
public are people paying a lot of
attention to this
absolutely i mean
there was so much um anger at the
corruption that had been happening um at
that time so much so that it was the
first time in history that his party
known as amnor which had been the
dominant party in politics was voted out
of power in 2018 and this was the first
time in history that they had been
booted out of power and a lot of it was
because of the anger um over the
corruption and ross marman so even at
the time when she was the first lady of
malaysia she was known for a very lavish
lifestyle and during the course of this
trial the court heard testimony from a
witness talking about how powerful she
was so much so that there was a special
department that had been set up just to
handle her affairs she wielded
considerable influence in government
even though she had no official position
now after the amno party was voted out
of power after the prime minister after
her husband najib razak was no longer
prime minister of malaysia the then
government that had been made that was
made up of opposition parties they
conducted an investigation against her
and eventually charges were filed
against her and also najib razak and
during the course of that investigation
as well police seized
luxury goods jewelry watches
expensive handbags worth millions of
dollars from residences linked to the
family
so
you know there is a lot of anger this
case is being watched very closely in
malaysia and i think there is a feeling
that justice is being done although of
course they do have supporters who
believe that the cases against them are
politically motivated florence thank you
very much indeed florence louis talking
to us from kuala lumpur